la victoire de françois fillon au lieu
de de créer une sorte de dynamique et de
rassemblement autour de sa candidature
va accentuer en réalité les fractures
[Musique]
fraîchement désigné candidat par la
primaire de la droite et du centre
françois fillon comment sa campagne pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2017 dans
un climat de division
après la primaire en fait on ne voit
plus françois fillon c'est à dire qu'il
prend quelques jours de vacances au
grand désespoir de son équipe qui lui
dit qu'il faut tout de suite agir tout
de suite voir nicolas sarkozy tout de
suite voir alain juppé et c'est vrai que
son équipe est assez désemparé
les élus et les militants aussi tout le
monde attend à un geste du vainqueur est
en fait la rencontre avec les deux
perdants de la primaire va avoir lieu
très très tard lui-même ne faisant pas
les gestes de rassemblement les
sarkozystes se met en retrait nicolas
sarkozy lui-même ce meurtre elle y passe
des coups de fil pour faire comprendre
que françois fillon ne le sollicite pas
ne l'appelle pas
c'est un peu vexant quand même et donc
ça ça laisse aussi des traces c'est à
dire que se souvient que pour la
primaire de la gauche il y avait eu
assez rapidement une photo de famille là
ça se passe pas de la même manière
françois fillon attaque prudemment sa
campagne et se fait discret il faut dire
qu'à l'époque il est le favori des
sondages il a disparu
il a laissé son directeur de cabinet
toute son équipe se débrouiller tout
seul et donc c'est là qu'on a pu mesurer
que il n'était quand même pas un bon
candidat pour une présidentielle
alors tout le mois décembre on ne voit
pas françois fillon qui est dans des
tractations pour constituer un
organigramme de campagne et en fait on
le retrouve le 3 janvier
2017 pour un déplacement à emmaüs et
puis donc s'installe la campagne mais
qui est pas très dynamique en tout cas
en ce début d'année c'est à dire qu'il
enchaîne pas non plus les déplacements
tout le mois de janvier va être égrainé
comme ça avec des petits déplacements
mais ça fait retomber le soufflé est le
25 janvier 2017 le canard enchaîné
révèle des soupçons d'emplois fictifs de
sa femme pénélope clients c'est le début
de ce qui deviendra la sphère fillon la
campagne à partir du mois de janvier
février quand les affaires commencent à
surgir les gens se posent des questions
parce que là pour le coup c'est françois
fillon qui avait mis sur le devant de la
scène au coeur de la primaire sa probité
et le fait que lui n'avait jamais été
bien d'examen le jour où le canard
enchaîné sort moi je suis avec françois
fillon qui est à bordeaux pour un
déplacement justement avec alain juppé
c'est la première fois qu'il ya ce
déplacement entre numéro un et numéro
deux de la primaire et ils visitent le
musées de bordeaux et à ce moment là
tous les portables des journalistes se
mettent à vibrer parce qu'on a tous des
alertes qui disent que il ya une enquête
qui va être déclenchées par le parquet
et donc il ya une certaine fébrilité qui
s'installe c'est à dire qu'à ce moment
là françois fillon lui même n'est pas au
courant
il en prend connaissance par son équipe
qui lui montre téléphone portable et à
partir de là il devient difficile de le
voir c'est à dire qu'il part du musée
dans une certaine
rapidité les touristes sont assez médusé
de voir que voyais un mouvement entre
des caméras qui essaye d'avoir une
réaction du candidat donc c'est assez
compliqué jour là dans un premier temps
au tour ont fait bloc et pluie peut un
peu ça s'enlise c'est pas seulement un
journal qui sort une histoire c'est des
juges du parquet fine du pnf du parquet
national financier qui lance une enquête
qui ouvre une enquête est donc là peu à
peu il va perdre le soutien d'un certain
nombre de responsables de la droite et
quand il sera mis en examen
il va effectivement déclenché une crise
interne très forte qui avait entraîné le
départ d'un certain de ce qui était dans
son équipe si je ne me trompe pas et je
crois que le jt de tf1 c'est le 26
janvier donc ces quelques jours après
les premiers articles dans le canard
enchaîné est en effet françois fillon à
cette phrase que seule mise en examen
pourrait le faire renoncer à l'élection
présidentielle sur le moment son équipe
ne sait pas qui va avoir cette phrase ça
aura sur certains en se disant s'il
déclare ça c'est que
vraiment il n'y a aucun problème est que
c'est qu'une mauvaise passe et d'autres
se disent attention prends cet
engagement devant les français il sera
obligé de le tenir
et quand il ne va pas le tenir plusieurs
semaines après beaucoup d'élus et de
militants lui en voudront ils se diront
là c'est plus possible je ne céderai pas
je ne me rendrais pas je ne me retirerai
pas face aux multiples accusations
françois fillon va essayer de se
défendre mais sa stratégie de
communication ne fonctionne pas là quand
la sphère sort du canard enchaîné
qu'est-ce qu'il faut répond non c'est
pas ces faux nom c'est vrai mais c'est
pas autant lui même vient des visions
pour dire oui je reconnais les faits
d'ailleurs j'ai aussi utilisé mes
enfants en stage au sénat
mais après on apprend que c'était pas en
stage et qu'ils ont vraiment va qu'ils
étaient employés qui mais qui n'ont pas
travaillé qu'ils étaient payés plus donc
lui-même sans sommeil les pinceaux et
des résultats tout sa parole est un peu
décrédibilisé et surtout son temps de
parole est utilisé à ça et pendant des
semaines et des semaines en fait il ne
va pas pouvoir faire campagne
il ne va pas pouvoir parler de son
projet il sera toujours un terreau
jusque là dessus il n'arrivera pas à
s'en dépêtrer
[Musique]
déplacement françois fillon sont
compliquées il est accueilli à de
nombreuses reprises au son des
casseroles il pense alors à jeter
l'épongé
juste avant le 5 mars le grand
rassemblement au trocadéro françois
fillon hésite un peu à se retirer
en tout cas c'est ce qu'il laisse
entendre à ses proches parce que tous
ses fidèles et même le premier cercle il
dit c'est plus possible il faut que tu
renonces mais ce rassemblement au
trocadéro et presque une divine surprise
pour lui parce qu'il ya énormément de
monde c'est très réussi et que la foule
de soutien et lui dit il faut continuer
et donc le 5 mars au soir il clôt cette
séquence d'hésitation en rappelant un 20
heures qui sera candidat jusqu'au bout
et donc sa ferme aussi la porte un
implant mais il a fait croire à beaucoup
qu'il allait démissionner qu'il allait
renoncer à sa candidature et finalement
il ne l'a pas fait ça s'est joué lors de
ce fameux week end ou c ou le dimanche
se retrouver ses partisans place du
trocadéro je pense que si on est honnête
on n'a pas cru à une victoire de
françois fillon est même le résultat 20
% des suffrages est plutôt une surprise
parce que la campagne se passe dans un
tel climat à la fin il y a c'est
tellement une difficulté à parler du
fond et finalement on ne parle que des
affaires que on se demande dans quel
état va finir françois fillon mais on ne
voyait pas gagné non plus les obstacles
mis sur ma route étaient trop nombreux
dans l'immédiat j'assume mes
responsabilités
cette défaite est la mienne et c'est à
moi et à moi seul qu'il revient de la
portée
et donc toute une partie de l'électorat
de droite va aller vers emmanuel macron
et sa personne n'avait imaginé que les
républicains passerait sous la barre des
100 barre symbolique des 10% en danger
pour
les républicains c'est d'être
définitivement dépossédé d'une partie de
leur électorat
[Musique]